[Music]
in conspicuous consumption new I like
the alliteration there submitted by
vegetable smoothie yeah what's all
visuality you haven't disappointed you
gave me a [ __ ] proof and it's movie
by itself it doesn't taste as great yeah
when you ask roots into it it's mean
yeah that's fruits and vegetable ratio
does it become a fruit or vegetables
anyone arranging that one Apple would
just make it all sweet anyways onto the
news a new book explains the drastic
differences in which in ways rich people
versus poor people spend their money
oh I could tell you already tell us
which one retiring
I got money but I got a poor mind no
money baby
rich people in that like money don't
[ __ ] exist because they'd been having
that [ __ ] for so long that is just like
breathing poor people they act like
money is always going to run away so
they spent it all before it runs away
hmm that's the difference
am i right tell me we're 100 percent
right actually oh not where you put it
but yes so this book it's called the sum
of small things a theory of the
aspirational class by Elizabeth current
hulking not funded so this book is
saying that poor people have always
attempted to imitate the rich by buying
things and to seem like they're rich
right rich people remember I said the
quickest way to become poor is to try to
prove that rich you did say that not
very true that is really true so rich
people they're constantly like shifting
their spending habits throw the poor
people off that strictly poor
[ __ ] if I like a juicer and
then all these portraits are buying
juices to look rich and then they get
[ __ ] because they already switched on
to something other buying like a bread
maker okay so poor people go buy
conspicuous goods right so like bling
and all that stuff and then rich people
they'll focus on in pick ewis good so
like though what looks sowcarpet
know so they'd rather spend their money
on like better education for their kids
or better travel so they can be you know
more work or should I go and get you
[ __ ] well
what education [ __ ] yeah it gets the
educated [ __ ] if I spent money for our
kid there's just going to be [ __ ] wet
vaginas walking down the street coming
to ya know how many math club Asian kids
you want to [ __ ] oh my god so many if
that was the chief all look at this
[ __ ] math whiz over here but he was a
rainbow yeah but I didn't get him out
Webb oh I got him when he was the most
studious no you got that but you got me
when I was uncle salmon that's what I
thought you would know if you salmon on
the strip and I thought both of y'all
were stupid he was [ __ ] you too Ben
wait so was it when you were smarter
when you're stupid I thought I was like
you were the smartest dumbest decision
of my life at a time when you would go
to you Shelia getting his life together
like this 1,000 views a video and that
was viral beckoning yes that's been more
on inconspicuous goods like domestic
services you know like hiring people
people called give you a massage stuff
like that oh yeah I like Mazur
I told me so they focus more on like
less visible for more valuable good eye
things you can't keep things you can't
show off yeah and like what things that
give you more opportunity it seems like
but hiring a maid buys you more time
exactly like getting an education I
could expend a lot of other things so
they it seems like they utilize mine
more as like a resource yeah to leverage
other life opportunities rather than
just splurge in it yep I do both what am
i you do not look at the shirt you're
wearing bro he's don't thank this is my
inconspicuous you said I saw the
portable office either you saw throw the
poor people off with that you save your
good spender you don't buy it you don't
sound dumb [ __ ] you probably got it on
Amazon on sale I don't look at sales no
more I just buy em d44 vivo mentality no
see I told you guys original gotta got
money what I got money in the bank so
call me new money baby
no saying that now that globalization
has really keep in goods and means I'm
more available wealthy Americans are
trying to spend their money more unlike
socially worthy efforts and their mother
housing so I guess it does don't what's
socially worthy like imma spend money to
be with my family
she said the education worthy the world
traveling the work was just too fancy
all things to increase your social
wealth yeah like if you're more educated
and you're more elevated in my social
status yeah effective I like buying
books
it keeps the tables level when you put
them underneath keeps my backpack heavy
when I would don't get a chance to go to
the gym when you buy a pretty like
little shelf like you have [ __ ] to put
in there definitely no I bought books
need to know they were his book
thanks for taking away my credit what do
you mean look her in it she gave it to
you that you read them but she uses them
as decoration I gave you ain't talking
you thankful now thinking um if the
terminology they use in this book is is
that like that like they literally say
you rich people poor people if I was a
poor person and I had the mentality of a
rich person I would find that quite
offensive they say low and middle class
okay if I make sense yeah talking
financial like financial test true and
extranet fact so lower middle class
spend to pretend that they're rich and
then the rich people just they don't
spend it like that yeah they really
don't I mean you hear it all the time if
there's like millionaires it up you need
to take that back because you know who
is changing that whole [ __ ] you guys
know who's changing that [ __ ] oh that's
[ __ ] sure sure oh but they are not
enriched they're like wealthy though
that's different your stupid rich what
does that mean that money waste not
anything yeah that's like the Arab money
where they could suck to wipe their ass
with gold bricks all right well then
that's not another level that this
people in this book will even know about
what there's so many rich people that
buy like name-brand goods and like all
they wear
is the finest silk from Agrabah but you
know to me like they got bit not gaudy I
think to them that might even be there
Hanes though it's not gaudy that's what
I mean so like they can't they can't
afford both they're in this book are
saying well party but do it this way
rich people do it that way
but the stupid rich yeah they do it oh
yeah they do it all hey get that
gold-plated [ __ ] Lamborghini but at
the same time they send all their kids
to [ __ ] I believed or whatever
there's people in like a Dubai they're
most sought-after car because they
already have Ferraris and Lamborghinis
and stuff is Dodge Charger or Ford
Mustang because that's hard to get for
them really yeah so they're like oh my
god I just got me a [ __ ] 2015 Ford
Mustang Jimmy was a peasant so what do
you think this book is written for then
it's probably not written for the is
really much I can make money I don't
know yeah seems like it's written for
the lower to middle class usually I kind
of help like are you poor change your
mind
yeah retro discount and then they cap it
off felt like upper-middle class change
your spending habits that's what they're
saying
second busting yourself rather than
trying to show off that you're rich if
your family is not from oil family that
owns a [ __ ] ton of oil that's never
going to end for the next hundred
generations then maybe you want to think
about making and saving money I wish I
was I had that oil money that's the oils
drying up well how come I couldn't be
born into like a rich Indonesian oil
family I follow this God histogram I
think he's like royalty what's his name
by Richard mojo leaders I don't know
what it is cuz it's hard to pronounce
I follow a guy like that to every time I
look at online you [ __ ] rich [ __ ]
life is just out land but they got a
cool life though yeah like everything is
like what like you're just you're on an
island now petting monkeys and then the
next day you're just like in Las Vegas
like were you doing what are you doing
do it bro I feel like in their world
there's no judgement like there's no
like oh you're not working for them it's
more like wait you work yeah I don't
have to work is that low I have to work
yeah it's such a different world how do
you feel useful when you're in that
position that's like I feel so useless
that's why I don't know right you would
think so I think if we distracted
because you're doing so many things that
you would enjoy yeah you would try to
sneak out to have fun yeah you probably
living life and doing the [ __ ] dude
probably making your own [ __ ] movie
hiring your own crew that's useful yes
so I think it's in your nature to do to
be productive yeah but now you just have
the means to make it happen sooner it
might be really shitty but at least
you're doing it you won't feel useless
you're hiring other people and I work
for you that's a wonderful life that's
true because I think like no matter why
your personality is just going to be
enhanced now yeah so like it's like
daddy I want to make a movie okay how
much you need like 50 mil okay spend it
wisely son that's why I want you to be
rich your quantitative I can be
magnified like a [ __ ] you'll be
rich too I'm going to try to help you
get rich because I need to see what your
house is going to look like your [ __ ]
car your hobbies it might be toned down
if jess is still around because she'll
have a say in sort of things and I know
that I told her my dream and she was
like mmm let's wait till we get there
and I'm like I know what you're doing
you're just not telling me no right now
but when the time comes you're going to
try to convince me that a gold-plated
room is not a good idea
that is a great do when you have your
[ __ ] dreams when you have your own
palette or your own mansion like I am so
down to do an oil painting self-portrait
of you holding whatever you want and
I'll just open up or yes Jess don't you
dare [ __ ] strip him of his dreams I
know you're watching this don't you do
that then let it be a part of oil
painting - I could do it [ __ ]
gold-plated room I want to see it so I
need a gold plate a room with a huge
slide that goes out of it
and it slams into a pool of soft gold
money so I could do the ducktales thing
though a soft gold-plated money get into
the crash and it's like as soon as I and
then there's like a sensor right so they
feel your body sliding through and then
it starts playing the song down blue and
then you can just sleep hey what's up
guys thanks for watching we are going to
regularly start posting content on the
JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there a lot video click over
here
[Music]